wow well i think we just gotta go oh no
mike oh my god what are you gonna do now
i'm gonna stick my head onto my kitchen
counter and eat that thing
wow mike that's commitment
[Music]
hey guys it's mike chan welcome to
another episode of cone heads on first
we
feast the sweetest coolest show on the
internet and i don't know about you but
nothing brings me back to my childhood
faster than the sound of an ice cream
truck but really what i wanted
was to one day try every single
item that's stored inside that magical
vehicle and today today is that day
this is for you little mike to join me
on this
crazy icy adventure is my good friend
keith from the
amazingly popular try guys you might
have seen keith's show
eat the menu where he just devours
entire menus from places like kfc
or popeyes or taco bell
and keith we are going all out on ice
cream today buddy all the classic
flavors are here
you ready for this i'm so happy to be
here you know i normally do a lot of
the menus and i will say that it always
hurts my stomach a little bit this one
will be a little bit tougher as i am
lactose intolerant
i was gonna ask you about that how are
you gonna handle this you know it's
gonna hurt
but pain is temporary everything is
about growth
and you know sometimes bravery is saving
the world sometimes bravery is putting
things in your stomach that you know you
can't handle
there's lots lots of different heroes
out there i'm just here to be a food one
so i got all my ice cream here from all
city ice cream which is based in seattle
and i know keith you got yours from
mike's ice cream
yeah how serendipitous right who could
believe it
let's take a look here's what happened
when we caught up to our respective ice
cream trucks
here we go
[Music]
this is tamika from all city ice cream
hi thanks for pulling up today
you're welcome thanks for having us
right we're here we're here with mike's
ice cream truck we've got some shaved
ice i'm going to try my hand and make
another shaved ice this is exciting
so since the pandemic started how has
that affected business fortunately for
us
ice cream is pretty essential so we've
been able to service a broader range of
people because while you know people
haven't been able to leave their homes
we've been able to deliver it to them
how many uh ice creams or ices do you
think you sell like in a summer
normally minimum i sell thousands the
shaved ice
and then i don't know how many thousands
just ice cream like in the regular cones
and others
but at least thousands and thousands yes
yeah well people love their ice cream
it's summer
it's the time to have it
how many trucks do you have over 30.
what was that yeah just driving around
jingles blasting that's right bringing
ice cream to first time people such as
yourself
this is why i love people like you you
are like
the santa claus of the summer that's
right
it really is beautiful there you are
little girl
here you go little boy and i notice you
guys have a lot of classic flavors like
is that
intentional what's so great about the
classics you know by having some of
those classics around it reminds people
of their childhood
bringing that popsicle to them just
brings back a lot of memories
well thanks mike i really appreciate it
i'm gonna enjoy this we both got gloves
so i think we can do this right that's
how it works
all right
[Music]
let's start off with this the bomb pop
when i think of like an ice cream truck
i don't know about yuki this is the
first thing that comes to mind
i mean this is like the iconic americana
in every movie
of 4th of july a kid has one of these
[ __ ]
it is like eating a fireworks display
for sure
should we go for it uh-huh okay
there's really no way to eat this that
isn't somewhat sexual in phallic
wow this really tastes like an
artificial version of artificial cherry
it's never
just like cherry it's always poppin
cherry
blazin blue radical strawberry
i wonder how many licks it took to
change my tongue color so i'm gonna
stick my tone out
ah uh it's not changed enough in my
opinion
no
i'm trying hard but also like please
don't turn this into a gift overall
i think this is very classic it's not as
good as
when you're a kid eating it but it takes
you back
i like the podcast i think it holds up
it tastes exactly like it did as a kid
and it really just tastes like chocolate
milk and i haven't had chocolate milk in
a while so this is a delight
it it is nice and creamy and it's just
just dripping the heck
out of itself onto my onto my kitchen
counter but it
it doesn't look good
it looks pretty horrible but it actually
tastes pretty okay
i want to just read off the description
of this strawberry flavored center in
artificially flavored vanilla reduced
fat ice cream rolled in cake pieces
i love it when the fda makes people be
honest
it smells crazy mike
i think it smells good all right i'm
biting him
wow you know what this is actually
really good i love it
this was one of my favorite things
growing up i would stop by gas stations
and i will buy this all right look at
the middle
it's like it's wearing a snazzy little
outfit so far of the things we've had
this tastes the most like a real dessert
all right keith we're just hitting the
tip of the ice cream iceberg
ready keep going bring on the ice cream
sandwiches
[Music]
all right next we're on to ice cream
sandwiches what do you got
so i have the classic classic like wafer
kind this is a neapolitan flavor which
is great because it gives you all the
options at once and then i also have the
big chocolate chip
kind as well yours looks huge
yeah it does look really decadent like
extremely overwhelming almost
let's do it
oh you know what i like this this is
good
i like it heck yeah baby yeah
yeah it tastes like someone made the
cookie
like inside a tree trunk or whatever
they make cookies
yeah and it's a good cookie
with good ice cream with crunchy
chocolate chip what's not to love about
this
mike while you keep eating on that one
i'm gonna open this other one that i
have
which is the very classic ice cream
sandwich these
were a staple of my freezer growing up
as a kid
the fun thing about this is this is
probably the stickiest treat
that doesn't look like it's going to be
sticky because at some point
this cookie itself starts to stick to
your fingers and shred
apart but you know what
it's still good is it i think i forgot
what that tastes like by now
it's kind of like a brownie oh it takes
your back
well those cookies were good but we got
to keep going and i've got a lot of
chocolate on my fingers now so what's
next
next uh let's go to cones
this is coma heads right it's gonna
cause
this is the classic this is the
king-sized drumstick
i remember that when you open this up it
just looks like a traffic cone cone
because ice cream cones have a nice dome
but these they stand straight up i like
the tip
all right this is my ice cream cone
fetish right here at the end part
oh yeah boy i know you're talking about
that little
chocolate at the end i don't know what
you do but i put that whole thing in my
mouth
so you get that crunch from the
chocolate it got semi-crunch from the
kong
and that melty freaking vanilla yeah you
drink it
like this like like it's a little udder
i'm so ready let's dive in
i love that crunchy chocolate on top
wow well i think we just gotta go oh no
mike
oh my god what are you gonna do now i'm
gonna stick my head onto my kitchen
counter and eat that thing
wow mike that's commitment why don't we
jump to the tip you know let's let's
let's do what we did is okay let's eat
it from the bottom all right bud
oh wow i was the best
wow there's so much chocolate in there
all right ready to jump onto the big
dipper
yeah the big dipper this one's a little
different from the previous one because
this one's got a lot more chocolate a
lot more nuts it's that classic
dairy queen style dip
shatters baby it's got a nice crunch man
it does i wonder if this has the
chocolate bottom though
i feel like they all have to as soon as
somebody did it
everyone else is like [ __ ] we gotta do
it
we gotta get in there well i'm gonna
skip to the end i'm gonna check it out
for us
let's do it oh yep
i don't know about you but i'm getting
like a little cream overload
and it just feels like i ate a stick of
butter
yeah i'm feeling pretty weird over here
too mike
all right keith you ready to continue on
our journey let's do it let's get some
novelty items up in here
let's go
okay let me go find them let me go find
them
all right so what do you got okay so i
got a powerpuff girls bar i got a sonic
the hedgehog bar and i have a looney
tunes tweety bird bar
a couple of these feature the famous
gumball eyes which are
infamous for being known as the eyes
never look good i got the power puff as
well and i got the spider-man
all right well let's start with the
power puff
look at this she looks possessed by the
devil
mine looks like it came about a horror
movie like it looked like a
zombie bit my powerpuff girl well
mike these smell crazy
oh holy oh oh that's
oh nasty in the world wow it smells like
lemon and it tastes
like banana are we supposed to eat the
eyeballs
all right we have to eat the gumball
eyeballs absolutely let's do it
oh god oh god it's hard this gum is
horrible
i do love how she looks without a little
eyeball joke
all right i'm jumping onto the
spider-man all right i'm going to go for
sonic the hedgehog
you know sonic oh wow
i feel like this this is another example
of sonic needing a character redesign
um do you see spider-man from this
spider-man
from my angle looks like he's not that
bad
i hope to god your sonic tastes better
than my spiderman
mine is similarly bad but a very
different flavor
and the gum is also really bad
look at this nightmare doesn't this kind
of look like a skull that's come alive
oh my god that that looks just
horrifying
like seriously it looks like a minion
melted
[Music]
like
don't do drugs kids all right buddy i
appreciate you sticking with me for this
whole entire ice cream journey
and we got one round left you ready for
this i'm ready mike
let's do it it's gonna be classics true
vintage
classics choco taco
can we start with the uh the snow cone
because i need something
refreshing in my mouth that's not a
cartoon character yeah let's do it
oh my god the smell is crazy mike
look at this packaging though this
packaging
is from a thousand years ago
and buddy there's a gumball is that
there's a gumball
disgusting did you see that there's a
gumball inside
also this ice cream can take an impact
let's try
i like it's a little cold yo this is one
of those things
this will turn your tongue into multi
colors
i don't know well something's wrong with
mine
all right you know what as artificial as
this is it really does taste like if you
walked up to a shaved ice guy or shaved
ice lady
and this is what they would give you
some shaved ice and a bunch of you know
bunch of syrup stuff
there's no way to consume this thing
two ball screwball oh that is bright
whoa remember when nickelodeon sold gak
yeah it looks like gak okay i'm gonna
try this i like that this is
at least edible whoa mike monte's crazy
oh it's called two ball screwball
because there's two bubble gum balls in
every cone
oh great that's what we've loved the
most
yeah i'm not doing that
what did you do i'm eating the garden
mic oh you ate it
oh my god it is crying sea gum
when his gum
[Music]
all right buddy it's been a long sweet
journey we're down to our last ice cream
the
choco taco how you feeling i'm very
excited for this you know i feel like a
lot of the treats we had to go through
today were not things i actually
would want to get but this one i want
i want it in my mouth i love tacos i
love
chocolates this is going to be good all
right let's undress it
wow oh look at that
[Laughter]
it eats like a taco i do wish
that it had better structural integrity
you know are the engineers watching
right now are furious
they're like who designed that piece of
garbage it's so
messy and and so freaking substantial
but
god dang this is delicious the flavor is
great the
um the ratios are really nice
it is like eating an ice cream cone like
we had before
but it's more fun because it's a taco so
it really has this novelty this is fun
about it
makes you happy makes you excited feels
good love it
[Music]
all right buddy that's the end of our
ice cream journey really great to have
you huh my friend is so nice to talk to
you hang out with you some ice cream and
guys don't forget to check out the try
guys and subscribe this guy puts his
stomach every single week on the line
he's an entire menu least you can do is
subscribe that's all i'm saying
well i appreciate it mike happy to be
here you're you're a king of
eating on the internet i'm glad that
we've been able to form a friendship
over these last few years i look forward
to seeing all the rest of these conehead
episodes
uh and thanks to the plug always a
pleasure my friend and as always i'm
mike cheng
and this has been coneheads see you next
[Music]
time
you